[Musique]
merci Jean-Pierre cher de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élue du Loiret mon
du groupe socialiste et vous êtes élu
depuis 22 ans ici au Sénat vous ne vous
représentez pas au prochain sénatorial
vous allez donc quitter le Sénat dans
les prochains jours on va revenir sur
les moments marquants de votre carrière
ici au Sénat mais d'abord on va regarder
ensemble l'actualité et d'abord
l'actualité toujours au Maroc près de
3000 morts après ce violon séisme des
zones sinistres est-ce que vous
comprenez la position du Maroc il ne se
laissait toujours pas l'aide de la
France je suis la regrette parce que
dans votre reportage là tout à l'heure
on a vu que des villages étaient
complètement isolés laissés à l'abandon
parce qu'il y a des éboulements etc et
la France est un grand pays qui dispose
de moyens
le président de la République a dit
qu'il serait mis à la disposition du
Maroc dès qu'il les demanderait
et je regrette que le Maroc dont je
respecte bien sûr la souveraineté de le
fasse pas vous comprenez ça illustre
tels catastrophes il faut passer
au-dessus des questions politiques ou
diplomatiques qui ont pu diviser l'autre
sujet d'actualité c'est la question de
l'immigration qui revient en cette
rentrée une tribune conjointe de
parlementaire de gauche et de la
majorité présidentielle a été publiée ce
matin dans le journal Libération pour
pousser la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension dans le texte vous ne
faites pas partie des signataires vous
jouez pourquoi parce que tout simplement
on ne l'a pas demandé certainement que
ça a été fait assez rapidement mais je
la soutiens totalement
intégralement et totalement pourquoi
et bien parce que je reçois tout le
temps dans mes permanence tout le temps
des personnes qui sont là depuis 6 ans 7
ans 8 ans qui ont un travail et qui ne
peuvent pas être régularisés qui ne le
sont pas qui reste sans papier c'est
absurde en même temps dans le BTP comme
dans la restauration et l'hôtellerie on
nous dit voilà on utilise on fait appel
à des gens à leurs compétences et ils ne
peuvent pas être régularisés donc il
faut des parlementaires de gauche
socialistes écologiste communiste allié
avec des parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle sur ce texte mais oui
parce que
il n'y a pas de frontière étanche et
quand on partage des positions vous
savez j'ai dit lors de ma dernière
question d'actualité au Sénat la
question de l'immigration il faut cesser
de l'exploiter il faut la traiter
il y a dans l'extrême droite et au sein
de LR une exploitation constante on nous
dit il y a trop d'immigrés tout cela
savez-vous que par exemple dans les
dernières années l'immigration familiale
a baissé que l'accueil des étudiants a
augmenté ce qui est bien lisez le
dernier livre de Monsieur Haran qui
montre qu'on véhicules tous les jours
des idées complètement fausses sur
l'immigration et notamment sur le rôle
de la France beaucoup de pays d'Europe
font davantage que nous alors arrêtons
d'en faire un sujet de polémique de tous
les jours mais c'est la ligne rouge des
républicains cette mesure est-ce que ça
veut dire que le texte est vous à
l'échec selon vous mais ils ont tort les
républicains ils ont tort il faut qu'ils
écoutent dans leur département ce que
disent les chefs d'entreprise du PME de
la restauration et de l'hôtellerie c'est
simple
et que là ça va créer un appel d'air si
on régularisation c'est une sorte de
fantasme l'appel d'air il y a toujours
eu des immigrés en France regardez
l'histoire de France au 20e siècle et je
vais vous dire quelque chose Oriane il
va y avoir plus à l'avenir parce que
lorsque l'on aura des pays envahis par
la montée des eaux et ben il y aura des
réfugiés climatiques donc il ne faut pas
se barricader et quand vous avez des
bateaux entiers qui coulent dans la
Méditerranée on ne peut pas être la
République française humaniste attachée
aux libertés et laisser les gens couler
mais du coup est-ce que le texte est
voit l'échec selon vous est-ce que cette
loi immigration pour aller
moi je souhaite de tout mon cœur qu'elle
soit votée sur la base naturellement de
position juste comme celle que défendent
mes collègues sénateurs et débutants
donc un compromis vous paraît possible
entre vos positions et celle des
républicains
je ne crois pas que ce soit possible sur
la base de ce que disent aujourd'hui les
républicains mais ils sont tort
d'exploiter constamment ce sujet qu'il
faut tout simplement traiter de manière
réaliste est-ce que ne pas faire de loi
sur l'immigration c'est pas faire le jeu
du rassemblement national il faut faire
une loi sur l'immigration mais il faut
qu'elle soit positive constructive et
réaliste voilà c'est tout il y a aussi
la question du référendum de
l'élargissement du référendum à la
question de l'immigration qui se posait
est-ce que vous êtes favorable vous à
l'élargissement de ce référendum
immigration je pense que l'article 11 de
la Constitution est mal fichue ça c'est
sûr aussi bien pour l'initiative
citoyenne des référendum que pour le
champ puisque aujourd'hui l'article 11
ne permet pas de faire des référendum
sur un grand nombre de sujets maintenant
je vais vous dire franchement que je ne
suis pas pour un référendum sur
l'immigration je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que sur l'immigration ce qu'on
doit faire c'est un ou plusieurs projets
de loi et ce qui est très frustrant dans
le référendum ce qui crée beaucoup de
problèmes c'est que vous votez oui ou
vous votez non lorsque nous sommes ici
au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée qu'il y a un
projet de loi une proposition de loi il
peut y avoir
10300 mille amendements et on va
travailler en commission en séance sur
chaque mot chaque ligne du texte vous
comprenez donc faire un texte le
meilleur possible sur un sujet comme ça
ça demande des heures de délibération et
ça demande qu'on puisse se prononcer sur
chaque ligne et chaque mot du texte à
cet égard le référendum n'est pas le bon
sujet on va voir l'actualité dans nos
régions vous savez sur dans cette
émission on fait le point sur
l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
chez vous à Orléans on trouvait Rick
Richard journaliste à La Nouvelle
République bonjour Eric merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous d'abord et Eric on va
on va évoquer avec vous l'actualité
politique pas loin de chez vous ce sont
les journées parlementaires du MoDem qui
se termine aujourd'hui c'est dans la
Vienne et plusieurs membres du
gouvernement s'y sont rendus on attend
même aujourd'hui Elizabeth borde
et ces journées parlementaires du MoDem
bien ont lieu dans un cadre plutôt
champêtre c'est tout près de La
Roche-Posay donc dans la Vienne une
petite cité thermale vous avez forcément
entendu parler qui est surtout connu
pour ses laboratoires cosmétiques et ses
produits dermatologiques on est ici au
cœur de la 4e circonscription sur les
terres du député Nicolas turquoise
député MoDem bien sûr et d'ailleurs sur
les quatre représentants à l'assemblée
que compte le département et bien deux
sont des élus du MoDem ce département du
Poitou est bien devenu en effet une
terre d'élection à tous les sens du
terme pour les centristes instant
département qui a donné lieu il faut le
rappeler qui a qui a donné naissance à
plusieurs figures politiques
contemporaines on pense bien sûr à René
Monory président du Sénat mais aussi
deux premiers ministres élites cresson
que le sénateur sueur connaît bien et
Jean-Pierre Raffarin tout son temps
commun donc d'avoir bâti leur destin
politique sur cette terre de la Vienne
c'est donc Nicolas courte Nicolas
turquois pardonne-moi qui avait lancé
cette invitation à ses collègues au
cinquante et un députés de son parti de
quoi donner de l'élan bien sûr à la
notoriété de cet ingénieur
agronome qui est un ancien militant de
l'UDF qui a été élu à l'Assemblée en
2017 les députés bien sûr et puis vous
l'avez dit plusieurs membres du
gouvernement se rendent depuis hier à La
Roche-Posay hier Marc fenault le
ministre de l'Agriculture militant modem
bien sûr de la première heure a pris
part à une table ronde lui ont succédé
le ministre du Travail Olivier du socle
celui des comptes publics Thomas
Cazenave et le ministre de l'Intérieur
venu présenter le projet de loi sur
l'immigration un projet chaud vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure aujourd'hui
dans le coin d'orgue pour le parti
centriste avec Christophe bechul le
ministre de l'Environnement Gabriel
Attal celui de l'immigration et ce de
l'éducation pardonnez-moi et ce midi la
venue de la première ministre Elisabeth
borne un plateau copieux varié pour le
modem composante assumée on le sait de
la majorité présidentielle toujours
rassemblé derrière son créateur
historique François Bayrou sa partie
auquel le député Nicolas turquois voit
un rôle de pivot de la politique
gouvernementale avec une capacité à
discuter avec tout le monde selon lui
pour créer des majorités les échéances à
venir celles des sénatoriales notamment
diront si cette recette fonctionne
toujours c'est évidemment à lire dans
vos pas américains vous avez une
question pour Jean-Pierre Sueur
Jean-Pierre soeur l'ancien maire
d'Orléans
oui jean-Pierre Sueur bonjour tout
d'abord alors vous allez tourner la page
de votre engagement sénatorial c'est
aussi toute une partie de votre vie
publique vous avez été député sénateur
ministre maire d'Orléans on l'a dit mais
ce que tout le monde ne sait peut-être
pas c'est qu'il n'y a pas que cet
engagement politique dans votre vie
aussi important futile vous êtes un
universitaire linguiste un homme de
lettres n'est un écrivain aussi vous
avez signé en 2021 notamment Charles
Péguy ou les vertiges de l'écriture un
ouvrage important consacré à l'auteur
saluer d'ailleurs par la critique on
vous sait attacher à la terre orléanaise
on est beaucoup servi mais on connaît
peut-être un petit peu moins le fait que
vous êtes aussi très attaché à la terre
du Nord à Boulogne-sur-Mer notamment où
vous êtes né et votre papa d'ailleurs
exerçait la profession de journalistes
demain on vous imagine encore plein de
projets alors ma question est très
simple
jean-Pierre Sueur savez-vous de quoi
sera faite tout simplement votre vie
après le Sénat
vous savez j'ai toujours pris des choses
comme elle venait je n'avais pas prévu
peut-être député ni d'être ministre ni
d'être mère d'Orléans ni d'être sénateur
la vie a fait cela plus la volonté
politique bien sûr j'ai adhéré au PSU
Parti socialiste unifié avec Michel
Rocard en 1969 et depuis je me suis
toujours engagé et je continuerai à
m'engager à porter mes convictions et je
ne vais pas rester inactif ça ne me
ressemble pas mais en même temps j'ai
considéré cher Eric j'ai considéré
qu'après 42 ans de vie élective sans
discontinuer 42 ans c'était bien j'ai 76
ans c'est bien de passer le relais donc
je passe le relais et je le fais en
toute sérénité voilà et puis aux amis du
qui s'intéresse à Charles Péguy et qui
sont dans la Vienne si j'ai bien compris
je dirais que il faut il faut beaucoup
lire cet auteur et je vais me pencher
sur un manuscrit un tapuscrit qui est au
centre PEGI d'Orléans le jeune François
Bayrou a fait un diplôme d'études
supérieures sur la comparaison des deux
gènes d'Arc de pays celle de 1897 et
celle de 2000 de
1910 voilà j'y arrive voyez-vous donc
Peggy c'est un auteur qui a été souvent
caricaturé mal compris très mal compris
de travers et aujourd'hui on a une
vision plus juste de Peggy qui est
quelqu'un qui dérange parce qu'il pose
des tas de questions dans tous les
domaines qu'il le faudrait peut-être pas
poser enfin c'est un écrivain qui est
considérable on va revenir sur vos
années parlementaires dans quelques
instants avec Steve mais puisqu'on est à
Orléans dont vous avez été maire on sait
les mers sont en première ligne de plus
en plus est-ce que vous iriez que c'est
le mandat le plus difficile que vous
ayez à exercer ou pas non j'ai toujours
trouvé que tous les mandats étaient
passionnants et j'ai eu de la chance
enfin j'ai eu de la chance
figurez-vous que quand j'ai été député
je ne réussissais pas à être mère puis
j'ai été lui-même et je ne réussissais
plus à être député puis j'ai cessé
d'être mère et je suis devenu sénateur
c'est-à-dire qu'en 42 ans j'ai cumulé
demanda pendant un an si bien que je
suis un partisan farouche du nom cumul
des mandats on a tellement de talents en
France que je trouve incompréhensible
qu'on demande au même d'exercer deux
trois quatre fonctions je trouve que
quand on
parle un peu coupé
je suis pas d'accord du tout quand on me
dit ça je dis bah écoute si tu trouves
que tu es coupé du terrain tu prends ta
voiture et tu vas tout les samedi tous
les dimanches tous les vendredis tous
les lundis voir nos concitoyens tu
ouvres des permanences tu prends tes
chaussures c'est un bon instrument la
chaussure Jean-Pierre Chevènement disait
que les godillots c'était quelquefois
utiles bon je n'en tire pas de
conséquence mais allez sur le terrain
vous n'êtes pas obligé de cumuler les
mandats pour aller sur le terrain
regardez moi j'ai un seul mandat depuis
22 ans et bien je suis considérablement
sur le terrain voilà on va continuer à
parler évidemment de vos mandats on
regarde la Une de La Nouvelle République
on remercie Eric Richard Eric la Une de
La Nouvelle République vous en avez
parlé ce sont ces journées
parlementaires du MoDem full de
ministres en Châtel rodé c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci Eric Richard
d'avoir été avec nous vous allez donc
quitter le Sénat Jean-Pierre sœurs on
l'a dit après 22 ans de mandat ce qui en
fait un des textes des rapports de
question d'actualité au gouvernement ça
ça en fait pas mal notre journaliste
parlementaire Steve Jourdain a plongé
dans les archives de votre mandat et
nous rejoint tout de suite